here at geek culture we love our laptops
and today we have a beast on hand the
msi raider ge67 hx-12
ours is the 12-view gs-014 sg model
which comes with the latest intel core
i7 12800 hx cpu nvidia 3070ti
16 gigs of ddr5 ram with support of up
to 64 gigs and a one terabyte ssd
if that doesn't sound like a beast to
you i don't know what is that's a lot of
power to look forward to and we're more
than ready to dive in
i've been waiting to open up one of
these things the raider comes in this
sleek box and let's just open this up
real quick
and here we have the radar
wow
violent packaging
unpacking yeah we also have the
instruction booklet
and last but not least we have
the power brick now taking everything
out of the box
this laptop looks like a gamer stream
with its classy titanium dark gray
finish and embossed logo just look at
that looks
man everything is styled perfectly
and oh
nice little bit of felt down here too
look at the keyboard looks really good
this weighs 2.3 kg and we'll be plugging
it in to see whether it passes my rgb
test
that is beautiful this panoramic aurora
lighting design powered by msi's mystic
light goes all around the front of the
laptop with eight key default options
you can switch things around to fit your
gaming profile for fps's mobas and mmo
titles and check this out real quick the
beautiful perky rgb lighting is powered
by the trusty folks at steel series
which makes typing on these keys feel
seamless smooth and stylish on the sides
we get a lot and i mean really like a
lot of ports msi really came prepared
with this connectivity offerings and i
got to list everything out first up we
have two type a usb 3.2 gen1 ports next
we have one type a usb 3.2 gen 2 port we
also have a type c usb 3.2 gen 2 port an
sd card reader which not many laptops
have nowadays and as a video and photo
guy thank you so much one thunderbolt 4
port hdmi port for 8k 60hz or 4k 120hz
displays and lastly the dc in port for
this power brick now on to the display
the 15.6 inch oled screen is visa
certified display
true black 600 which means you'll get
amazing colors out of this
it also features a 240hz refresh rate
with 0.2 millisecond response time and
qhd resolution so you can watch your
enemies die beautifully audio-wise the
raider has got you covered with this
dynaudio sound system with two dual wave
speakers on either side of the laptop
with this audio and visual fest we have
going on msi promises a true to live
gaming experience and we put it through
some benchmarking tests and the radar is
equally powerful for video editing here
are some benchmarking scores for 3d mark
pro pc mark pro and ul president office
productivity photo editing and video
dating benchmark we ran the time spy
benchmark on the radar and it's called
11791
the radio also has a score of 7267
on pc mark 10 and lastly it's got
6334 for prescion and just to test it a
little further we played some apex
legends forza horizon 5 and doomy tunnel
so we ran apex legends at 125 fps and it
ran both forza horizon 5 and doom
eternal at about 80 to 90 fps
now i know what you're thinking zin
that's all very cool and all but what if
it overheats and just
msi has taken that into account of
course to introduce the cooler boost
five which basically consists of two
fans and seven pipes and now that's a
lot of pipes for heat dissipation and if
you want to make things even cooler the
thermal pack comes with the phase change
feature to prevent crystallization which
basically means
cooling for days cooling for days msi is
also packed in a battery capacity of
99.9 watt hour which basically means you
can legally bring this in on a hand
carry and do away with in-flight
entertainment not only that but if
you're someone who demands maximum power
msi has got you covered with the hx
series raider ge77 and the titan gt77
thanks to msi's over boost technology
the laptop can run at a whopping 250
watts of power and to break it down
that's 175 watts from the gpu and 75
watts from the cpu the raider g67
hx12ugs014sg
is designed to be both an on-the-go and
workplace workhorse and gets the job
done in several ways improved cooling a
whole slew of ports and a vibrant color
accurate all that display now we've had
a wonderful time taking this for a spin
so if you have any questions leave them
down in the comment section down below
and i'll do my best to get to them and
with that
this is zinio and i'll catch you guys
soon
so take care
[Music]